i'm only allowed to sing songs where i
yell because i like
i don't think because if i i think i
would be a stripper
did you say if i couldn't do it god
could not trust me with a singing voice
he knows like he knows who he can trust
oh my gosh i would be that person like
how you doing
yeah yeah i'm dropping like
chocolate testimony would be my stripper
name chocolate testimony i had the whole
thing planned out but that's why god's
like
i've got to make that show
it keeps me humble like something like
it i can't have six-pack abs because
again
i would wear pasties to church and i
just don't think that's appropriate i
think that god would frown i think i
think he'd be like daughter
what are we doing so he keeps me humble
with like a humble pouch and like uh
i always say that about some hike i was
like when i see some hike i'm like god
didn't allow me to look that good for a
reason i would be
just walking around naked she's so
beautiful
you have to know your limitations and he
knew them before you know like yeah
you gotta you gotta do you girl please
you are so funny want more fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure